britain has moved to strengthen its
border controls against the omicron
variant but the question remains what we
and other nations should do to reduce
transmission at home the answer from our
closest neighbours ireland is a return
to restrictions from tuesday night clubs
will close sports events and theaters
will be restricted to 50 capacity there
will be a rule of six in restaurants and
no more than four households can mix at
home ireland had only a single confirmed
omicron case when these rules were
announced but it is dealing with a steep
spike in delta cases the seven day
average has increased by 58 percent in
the last month now the same is true in
germany where delta cases are up 138
since november and hospitals are
beginning to struggle prompting
restrictions on the unvaccinated those
who've not had a jab or not recently
recovered from kovid are banned from
shops bars and restaurants football
crowds will be capped at fifteen
thousand people and there's a drive to
deliver 30 million vaccinations by the
end of the year france has lower
absolute numbers than germany but delta
cases there are up more than five-fold
but with hospital admissions increasing
more slowly it's sticking to existing
rules requiring proof of vaccination to
enter consumer venues and public
transport now the uk had the lowest
level of restrictions in western europe
and delta cases rising far more slowly
up just 14 in the last month in response
to omicron mark wearing has been
reintroduced in shops and on public
transport in england but the main
intervention is to boost the vaccine
program while leaving social contact
unchecked
i am genuinely genuinely worried but
you know we're two years into this
pandemic these variants continue to pop
up and we need to find sustainable
solutions and i think lockdowns can
increasingly are are you know just cause
so much damage they have to be an
absolute last resort
while europe is facing a winter wave of
delta only a few hundred cases of
omicron have been detected but as long
as its severity and rate of transmission
are unclear different restrictions will
reflect political choices in the face of
uncertainty